it wouldn't be the holiday season
without one final scare from Anthony
fauci the lockdown lover bidding
farewell as President Biden's chief
medical advisor while doing his best to
prevent you from enjoying your
Thanksgiving feast fauci making his
final guest appearance at the White
House briefing and sounding like it's
still 2020.
you say about the word mask now being a
pejorative I know sometimes when you
walk in and you have a mask and nobody
has a mask you kind of feel guilty you
shouldn't feel guilty you look terrific
the real danger isn't the people who
have not been vaccinated so that's where
we expect if we're going to see a
problem this winter it's going to be
among those people so my message and my
final message may be the final message I
give you from this Podium is that please
for your own safety for that of your
family get your updated covid-19 shot it
looks like fauci must have missed the
key new detail with warning America
according to the Washington Post for the
first time ever vaccinated people now
make up a majority of coveted deaths by
58 and while the White House can't let
go of covid another huge Health crisis
is sweeping across the country
pharmacists are running out of
Children's Tylenol after a crippling
antibiotics or shortages more and more
kids are being hospitalized with the
debilitating RSV which is a respiratory
virus
okay Lawrence I'm going to start with
you were you happier or sad that that
was fauci's last press conference uh I
think most of America is excited about
that she's leaving
um it wasn't always that way Doug I
think the American public people in the
the media even I said Fox we praise fast
at the beginning but it became the it
was the lies that did the marker for him
and he's the type of liar that lies
because I want to help you and it
started with the mask if you guys
remember we didn't have a mask issue
before people were rushing to the store
they were hoarding the supply everybody
wanted a mask and then thou she along
with some of the other White House
doctors went out there and they said the
mass don't work so people stop getting
them that wasn't true the mass didn't
work was just a total lie they wanted to
hoard the Supply right for the folks
that were working in the hospital he
could have just told the people that
then it was the vaccine he said okay if
you get the vaccine you can't die from
covet we all know that was a lie they
knew that was the lie at the time but he
said he did that because he wanted
people to get the vaccine and then the
final thing and this is just the one
that we still need answers on was when
it came to gain of function he know for
a fact that we funded every research he
know what he did he played a semantic
game with Rand Paul but in his eyes they
needed to get ahead of the research they
needed to know what the buyers could
potentially do so it was necessary well
you know what Dagan one of the questions
one of the final questions was to fauci
can you tell us about the origin of
covet a perfectly fair question given
that Millions died across the world and
yet there was like a defense from Kareem
Jean-Pierre which I'm going to ask Greg
about but I'll go to you on the issue of
you know why was that something that he
shouldn't have to answer because the his
division at government was funneling
money through the Eco Health Alliance to
the very lab that could be the site very
likely the site of the coronavirus he's
going to get call on Capitol Hill
to talk about this
let's take a listen
hold on one second
we have a process here I'm not calling
out on people who yell she has a valid
question she's asked me about the origin
of coffee I hear the question what the
[ __ ] she's the best person I hear your
question but we're not doing this the
way you want it this is a disrespectful
it is I'm done Simon I'm done I'm Simon
I'm done I'm done with you right now
wow I'll let you just finish on that
thought and then I want to go to Greg on
Korean Jean-Pierre no the only nice
thing I have to say about Tony fauci are
too Tony fauci is bye don't let the door
hit you where the good Lord split you
actually I hope the door does hit you on
the ass goodbye he is a contemptible
partisan power hungry Bureau hack
and the danger is he's a perfect example
of why somebody should never be in a
position of power for that long he is he
was to paraphrase Brit Hume he is an
epidemiologist you should have been in
charge of fighting the disease not our
economy not our children's development
not businesses not our children's
education none of it trillions of
dollars of wealth was destroyed because
of him businesses were crushed children
had been set back for their lifetimes
and he we're on a financial trajectory
to a a horrible burden in the coming
decades and he'll never pay the price
and I guarantee he gets a job from some
left-wing hack you know what Greg and
what she didn't mention is the money
that he makes off of Med medical
Pharmaceuticals well let's talk about
Kareem Kareem Jean-Pierre okay does she
have a right to do what she did and shut
people down I mean we can't ask a decent
question the one question the world
wants an answer to without her uh you
know running defense for this guy yeah I
mean imagine if a republican uh back in
2001 you know lashed out from the podium
if somebody asked about 9 11 like can we
do what do we know about not whoa not
this is the most important question in
modern history people should want to
know how their relatives died uh but
then again she's not honest about crime
or inflation you can't expect expect
them to be honest about this I love that
when they referred to fauci as a guest
like he's Taylor Swift making a cameo to
impress The Starry eye members of the
press he is still an employee who is
required to ask questions he's not a
celebrity he's a civil servant who like
you said makes a lot of money he makes I
think 800 Grand from the government
alone this again is like love them or
hey to me you got to bring up Trump
because you always have to do this
comparison and that is He Still Remains
the most transparent politician I've
ever seen whether he was right or wrong
he still loved the asking questions even
the dumbest questions he would ask and
oftentimes the dumbest questions would
get the most interesting answer that's
the question that was asked by the
reporter is precisely the question Trump
was asking like where is this crap
coming from that's what makes him closer
to Americans than say these gain of
function deniers that are currently
trying to cover their ass and I
understand why because I think that
America
when we can't just blame China on this
if we're behind the if we're paying for
this exactly so what's going to happen
is that we may have a little bit of
blood on our hands because we're paying
for the gain of function which created
this thing and uh as for JP it's amazing
how she doesn't even pretend that she's
trying to do her job do you know what I
mean at least pretend you're doing it
but you know she's operating under lower
standards right you know I mean she took
the right boxes she doesn't have to do
her job yep and she's not great at it
and by the way I mean it doesn't matter
she's a spin doctor she's not someone
who gives information to the American
people no she hasn't even gone to
medical school she's not a doctor
Jessica the question that I have of you
is it was fauci's Agency on the Niah
that gave five million dollars uh in new
brands for the same Wuhan link group
Echo Health Alliance despite U.S
intelligence assessing a lab release was
there was one of only two explanations
you know and yet everybody on the left
is defending him well I think there's a
difference between defending Anthony
fauci and saying that we should
understand where a disease that killed
millions of people across the globe and
over a million Americans came from I've
been consistent on that I want to know
exactly what happened there were a
number of stories starting with a
Pangolin whatever that is in a wet
market and ending up now where most
people who I talk to and they're
generally of the liberal persuasion
thinks that it came from a lab and they
would like to know what happened there
so that feels like a real piece of
bipartisan agreement that we can go to
and there are other Western democracies
I believe majority of them that also
fund gain of function research we're not
going to be the only ones that were
linked with funneling money into this
lab why is the press secretary not
allowing the question to be asked of him
that is so far above my pay grade it
would not be how I comments all the time
what am I supposed to say I would answer
the question if I was the Press
secretary I would answer the question or
I would say to my boss I have to answer
this question guys that I talked about
about a line about mask a lot about the
vaccine so I think and you did you did
admit that it was other Trump other
officials of the administration Jerome
Adams who was the Surgeon General who
has since apologized for it I think that
they didn't know what to do when
resources were so scarce and obviously
doctors and nurses and the people who
were working in the hospitals First
Responders were the ones who needed
those masks more than those of us who
could stay at home America doesn't do
that we don't get to choose who the mass
everybody matters everybody life matters
everybody was still roam in the street
everyone deserves the mask doctors
working in the ER deserved masks more
than me period end of story can I just
comment on a couple things Dagen said
Anthony fauci is this blatant partisan
he served in multiple Democratic and
Republican Administration he is not a
partisan stop
stop to the point about Trump being the
most transparent about this Carl
Bernstein has him on tape admitting that
he knew that the disease was Airborne
even though he came out and told
Americans that it wasn't
and I want to say something about
Tylenol and RSV because I went to my
pediatrician with my daughter who's
turning one and it was the only thing
that she talked to me about about
keeping kids out of they go to these
little baby classes you know they go to
a playground infect each other right and
I'm lucky I I had bought two bottles of
Tylenol that's a really serious crisis
if those shelves are empty of Children's
Tylenol going into the holidays and you
know what the shelves are empty they're
showing all kinds in States up the
Eastern Seaboard shelves
I hope it doesn't turn into the new
formula crisis but that's something
there are no there are no options like
there weren't before you can't give them
a regular dose of any drugs so that has
to be dealt with right away she said
AIDS was airborne and it wasn't good
times
when he focused on the vaccine I wanna
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now